this is a production of Cornell
University
morning everyone I'm glad to have a
chance to talk with you about deer and
deer related impacts I've been involved
with deer research on campus for about
25 years and it's a constant problem
that doesn't seem to go away that only
gets worse in many parts of the state so
I want to talk about a bit on deer
biology and management and some of the
things that we've done locally over the
last few years in terms of research to
try to get ahead of some of these issues
and we're far from solving the problem
but I think when a couple local
communities we're starting to make some
inroads all where there's lots of
associated impact with deer from a
health and safety and economic
standpoint deer-vehicle collisions are
the biggest one and we estimated we hit
probably a hundred thousand deer a year
nobody knows there are no exact figures
because every municipality every police
organization tends to tally things a
little bit differently we worked with Ag
and markets in New York Farm Bureau and
did a survey a deer damaged agriculture
back in the early two-thousands and
realized that deer at that time we're
causing about 59 million dollars a year
in economic impacts agriculture in New
York State in the plant industry alone
if you look at the horticulture industry
probably roughly around 10 million
dollars of losses so again these are
pretty large economic impacts for one
species we're going to talk about
damaged primarily woody or terminals and
perennials today forest regeneration
failure is another big issue with deer
we've got a current project with New
York State DC looking at trying to
assess deer forest impacts and forest
regeneration failures and if you change
habitat then that influences things like
song birds reptiles and amphibians and
if you change the species diversity of
all mammal that really influences ticks
and tick borne diseases so all these
things tend to be interrelated and will
touch a little bit on all of them what
can we do if you've got deer problems in
and around your community there really
depends on the scale for example on an
individual property probably the most of
cost effective thing or some type of
exclusion devices and we'll talk about
each of these people tried frightening
devices with pretty poor success plant
selection I'll touch on some things mark
bridge is gonna follow up later with
some more detailed list plants that tend
to be deer resistant I'll talk about
repellents and population control and if
you think of an IPM contact what you're
trying to do is look at the best
combination of what's available that
fits your landscape or your property to
try to get the damage down to a
tolerable level so exclusion can be
something as simple as say black heavy
netting on metal stakes and a garden
small garden kitchen garden type of bed
people have tried monofilament lines on
different configurations deer tend to
figure those out pretty quickly they so
they tend not to work very long all
sorts of types of fencing high tensile
woven wire is the most expensive it's
also the most resilient to deer damage
and all sorts of other metal and wire
guards that you might see commercially
sold but if you can keep the deer away
from the plant materials at the times
when they're sensitive that generally
solves the problem over the long haul
frightening devices you'll sees all
sorts of these squawk boxes that emit
sounds that are supposed to scare deer
we tested a shuru device years ago that
was supposedly scared scaring gear out
of apple orchard - did absolutely
nothing
most of the auditory devices deer are
smart they figure out what's real danger
and what's not if they hear a noise
several time nothing happens they're not
going to pay any attention to it
visual repellents the same thing I've
seen people put coyote decoys out and
around their firearm and planning golf
courses I've seen them use these coyotes
to keep deer and geese away and and both
the deer and geese quickly figure out
that those our decoys are not real they
present no real danger and so they're
our waste of time and money
odor repellents are useful we'll talk a
bit about that when I get to the
repellent section then ultrasonics and
I'll talk about more about that
ultrasonics haven't shown have any real
success with deer but I'll mention it
briefly when you get to the vehicle
collisions lots of repellents most of
the products today are formulated with
the generally regarded of safe materials
because they avoid EPA registration with
the grass listed compound unfortunately
most of them have never been tested
under replicated experimental settings
and I would doubt looking at active
ingredients a lot of those things work
at all
there is one chemo sterilant registered
for deer nationally by a federal EPA
that it's not registered in New York
gonna con immuno contraceptive vaccine
is registered but but not used in very
many states it was an experimental drug
for controlling deer populations high
cost high expanse continued maintenance
and it just you know just a delivery
system isn't that great terms of
population control most state wildlife
agencies New York included will try to
first solve problems with managed
hunting and there's lots of different
ways to hunt deer you have to focus on
the female segment of the her because
that's your reproductive segment it's
going to control your population biology
so you can do things like DMPs your
regular doe tags that any hunter can get
in most parts of the state if you go up
a level more intensive management d
meant deer management assistant program
tag those are eight littlest only tags
issued to individual landowners usually
farm or forest landowners we had them on
university properties for many years and
they allow you to take a specific number
of antlerless deer and during the
regular hunting season the landowner
applies flow tags used to be I think a
50 acre minimum acreage requirement give
the tags out recruit hunters and try to
remove that on this deer the next step
in up and aggressiveness deer damage
permits these are tags to be used
outside the normal hunting season most
of the permits are given out for
agricultural grower for example you got
our strawberry grower going to try to
get a crop off in June and deer coming
in at night hammering the strawberry
they can apply for a deer damage permit
they're usually issued very quickly set
number of tags decided on by the
regional D you see deer biologists and
these are non hunting methods it allows
the use of bait artificial lights
shooting at night usually til 11 p.m.
Dec will look at the damage estimated
number of tags needed if the the
landowners got safe shooting zones and
then finally Deer Management focus area
the last thing that was started in 2012
the only one in the state right now is
here in Tompkins County area
we have a special deer focus area cuz
we've done so much research and
management activity what that allows is
any licensed big-game hunter in New York
State can apply and get free antlerless
tags online from the DZ website of a
register and every hunter can take two
antlerless deer per day every day of the
entire hunting season in addition they
can take two analyst deer per day during
a special three-week january season
that's the only 1 January season in
upstate New York so again we're putting
a ton in hunting effort in this area has
it done any good in reducing our gear
impacts I would say no hasn't made a
measurable difference and that's one of
the points I want to try to get accross
usually hunting programs alone no matter
how intensive they are just usually
don't they help there's no doubt they
help but they aren't going to solve a
problem because deer are smart they
figure out the safe havens very quickly
and you you've got to be smart and know
deer behavior and how to hunt deer and a
handful of skilled hunters on a damage
permit can do more than 400 hunters on
regular hunting season it's just the way
it is and I'll show you some data in a
while deer related vehicle accidents
nationwide back in the early 90s there
was a national survey done it was
estimated there were seven hundred
twenty six thousand nationwide that Dan
Decker did some surveys here in New York
and found of the accidents that actually
occurred only to 20 to 50 percent ever
got reported anywhere on a police
database or an insurance claim and so we
can certainly say well about half the
accident got reported for that seven
hundred and twenty-six thousand all
jumps up to a million and a half likely
deer accidents in a single year that
numbers probably gone up and at an
average cost back then a $3,000 per
vehicle for repairs that's four point
five billion in economic losses annually
I just saw some current data now
average based on insurance records about
$6,000 per vehicle on average for repair
so those numbers you just all escalated
over time we know a lot about gear
behavior we know 60% of the deer-vehicle
actions that occur in New York every are
going to occur during october/november
in December in November's two worth
month every year what's going on in
November that cause of that right it's a
mating season Bucks were chasing doe the
deer aren't paying attention they're
crossing roads more frequently and more
get hit
also that what's going on when you get
to the change in the daylight savings
time and the standard time it puts the
peak and deer activity at sunrise and
sunset right at the peak of driving time
morning and evening and so the
combination those two things causes
accidents to really spike at that time
of year there's another little blip
these data don't pick up right here in
May and June there's actually if you had
real data for it we pick it up from our
caller dear what's going on and late-may
early-june fawning season so what
happens before the adult female deer
give birth to this year's Fond she gets
last year's fawns out of her home range
and so you've got yearling deer for the
first time with no mother
and they're gonna have to go out and set
up their own territory and they're
wandering everywhere just watch the main
of highway quarters i-81 i nine you just
watch and you'll see that blip if you're
if you watch particularly at that time
of year so what can we do education for
motorists is really important they get
lots of PSAs and announcements out the
problem is we don't change our behavior
very readily look how long it took and
how much enforcement it took to put
seatbelt laws in place look how about
enforcement on texting and driving and
calling and trying to call on your phone
and driving just education alone just
doesn't solve unless you've got
enforcement behind it got to be careful
driving your dawn or dusk peak times of
deer activity deer creatures a habit
where you see deer across the road once
you're likely to see them again in your
normal daily travel so again note those
places in the back your mind when you're
traveling
to work or school or wherever scan the
roadsides for eye reflections know what
those look like at night that might give
any extra two seconds slow down if you
can recognize an eye reflection and miss
a deer versus having an accident and I
always encourage communities to manage
her density where possible because it's
a direct density dependent function the
higher deer density on the landscape the
higher probability of contact you're
going to have on high-speed highway
bells and whistles don't work there's
lots of ultrasonics and gimmicks that
have been sold over the year none of
these things have any effect on deer
behavior it's not even clear that deer
could hear in the ultrasonic range that
these devices produce think about
animals that communicate by sound long
distances the whales the elephant they
use infrasound that very low spake
spectrum think about somebody with a
young driver pulling up with a bass
under vehicle next to you boom boom that
really carries ultrasounds the exact
opposite your tires on your car probably
produce more ultrasonic noise and these
things do and so again that's just a
waste of time well I'll talk a little
bit about ticks anybody that's working
outdoors in the plant industry needs to
be where ticks and tick borne diseases
because they're on the increase the two
dominant species we've really got to
worry about our black legged or deer
ticks you can see how small the adults
are I suspect most of all you've heard
about Lyme disease and can recognize
black legged tick the other one on Long
Island in southeastern New York that's
getting to be a equal importance if not
more so is the Lone Star tick named for
the white spot on the back of the female
Lone Star's transmitter licky osis which
has very similar symptoms to Lyme
disease one of my field staff that was
working with Dan Gilroy down on Long
Island years ago had several tick bite
thought she had contracted Lyme disease
went to their doctor and got tested
twice and although I'm tests kept coming
back negative so if I said well test for
this whole panel is four major tick
related diseases sure enough she had
ehrlichiosis was treated for that and
recovered fine but again there's more
than one disease
got to be aware of so again the Lone
Star kick is the primary vector for
ehrlichiosis black legged tick
anaplasmosis is really on the increase
in different parts of the of New York
State you got to start watching for that
one line you're all aware up but VCO
sits I haven't seen much recent data on
that but there's more than one tick
borne disease out there and if you've
been bitten by ticks you know it you're
not feeling well see a physician as soon
as possible let's see if you can sort it
out because usually it's those top four
diseases the ones that they screen for
when they do that incomplete IgA IgG
panels so what can we do how can we
manage tick borne diseases such Lyme a
lot of communities are trying to reduce
deer numbers and I put question marks at
there because the data are not
encouraging on reducing deer number past
Island studies and past research has
shown for black legged tick populations
to crash you've got to get deer
densities below about six to eight deer
per square mile then there's not enough
deer in the landscape to perpetuate and
keep the Lyme disease and tick spreading
so what would folks gasps average deer
densities around here are if I went over
to West Hill just on the other side of
town what would you guess deer densities
might be on West Hill
anybody got a number you can throw out
what's that twenty to thirty per square
mile that's about a hundred short
everywhere I've measured around here
with infrared triggered cameras I pretty
consistently come up with about 120 to
125 deer per square mile
that's what was in village at Keuka
Heights before we started a program we
had close not quite that high on campus
we had a bottle just under 100 gear per
square mile northeast area where we've
done camera surveys we've come up with
125 deer per square mile that's pretty
typical suburban densities and
particularly in non hunted areas so
what's your chances of getting down to
six deer per square mile you've got a
hundred plus on the landscape
it's almost near zero so that's why
question it will help and probably not
so I don't want to sell something I
don't think is going to work
realistically Oh
eastern Long Island's worse than around
here when I was doing work out on
Shelter Island we were estimating
density than 250 force per mile on
Shelter Island eastern Long Island just
incredibly high gear densities marked
well aware that probably we'll talk
about it so when you've got high deer
densities you want to protect plant
materials fencing takes food or protect
areas fencing is the best thing so what
I recommend the communities of
tick-borne disease or problem defense
children's playgrounds fence small
public areas where there's high chance
for interaction of particularly children
and where you don't want deer on the
landscape self application of acaricide
zypher meeting with the floor poster
devices we tested the long island over a
three-year period again working with Dan
Gilroy down there we saw about a 95
percent reduction in tick numbers on
Long Island with a floor poachers but in
New York State they're only registered
for use on Long Island right now I can't
use them anywhere else and the issue is
potentially baiting deer and potentially
increasing population so unless
something changes with Bureau of DC
bureau wildlife that's a very limited
tool
the four-poster device is that picture
on the right it's a big corn hopper I've
got 200 pounds of corn in it and it's
got these sort of paint rollers on
Springs 2 on each end and a feeding
trowel and a certified pesticide
applicator comes in weekly measures of
the amount of corn consumed in the
device can estimate number of deer
visiting and that knows how much spray
from Ethan's spray to put on the roller
so when the deer reaches its head into
the device itself medicating just like
Promethean and a dog collar or something
and it really does if you can get the
right density devices out really does
cut back on tick loads and number of
ticks of deer or carrying yeah that's
absolutely right
and so again and that's part of the
concern Dec has you're not doing that's
addressing any of the other issues
you're only addressing the ticks you can
do some landscaping type of things for
blackleg of ticks and again this doesn't
work as well for Lone Star tick Sloan
stars are more of a warm season tick
there were a series but black legged
ticks are more of a cool season tick
they like shaded cool moist area so you
can try to put wood chip pads for
example around your yard and then keep
the yard well mowed and cleaned not
having in debris so that you can try to
get create a barrier between the tick
habitat and the earth that doesn't mean
a deer can't wander across your yard and
not drop a tick but the ticks themselves
won't migrate very large distances
because they desiccate easily in full
Sun or across very dry areas talk a
little bit about landscape plant damage
back in the mid-90s there was a national
survey done by Mike Connor or any
estimated there were about 250 million
dollars in damage to the plant industry
back then I think that's a huge
underestimate we did a survey in
Westchester County alone back in the
late 1980s and found over six and a half
to nine and a half million dollars in
plant losses in one County in New York
State so I think the way that national
survey was designed they just missed a
whole lot of damage back then plant
replacement cost averaged about $500 per
home with deer damage but the really
important thing is we learned that
things that are ever
woody ornamentals that are evergreen
used wrote again and our providing are
the plants that are most frequently
damaged by deer during the winter months
and they select them out in the
landscape so what can we do
reducing damage repellents work best
when the deer pressure in damages light
short-term and most areas in New York
State now are beyond that to be honest
fencing provides the only reliable
protection when the deer damage gets
moderate to heavy again trying to manage
deer densities and keep numbers down we
know each adult deer eats six to eight
pounds of forage a day when their your
precious plant materials that's a lot of
plant materials that they can go through
you can choose plants that are left
tractive I'll mention a few things
Mark's gonna follow up and talk much
more about that and I want to emphasize
deer feeding is illegal in New York
State some people still like to feed
deer and if you're feeding particularly
within 300 feet of a public highway you
will likely get a citation from the
environmental conservation officer all
sorts of fencing barrier gardening you
can put up an 8-foot high woven wire
fence that's pretty much the Cadillac
but yet it's completely deer proof in
the last 25 years so you put your car
stuff on front and not worry about it
for a while the lower-right homeowner
design all sorts of types of fences that
one has four-foot high wire barrier on
the bottom and single strands of wire
we're flagging up above that the upper
right is the Cornell Arboretum where
they cage individuals trees and shrubs
they want to protect and plastic netting
on a wooden stag stake so there's all
different ways to protect plant
materials from deer it's just again well
fits your budget and your cost and how
much air you do you need to protect we
know from past research that several
commercially available D repellents do
provide some success big-game repellent
or deer way and repeated trials we've
done has been our best option so far the
active ingredients putrescent egg solids
deer hate the smell of Petrus and eggs
hinder is relatively decent it's a soap
based product very wide labeling if you
use it on food crops to deer off did
fairly well it's calm
of the petrous neg solids and capsaicin
the bow night rabid deer repellent used
to be thigh room it got sold that label
got sold now it's essentially the same
ingredients as deer off hot sauce is
capsaicin you know what that hot peppers
taste like very high concentration of
that very good deer and elk repellant
tree guard is a bittering agent
denatonium benzoate deer pay almost no
attention to bittering agents don't
waste your time and money on those
plants are full of bitter compounds @d
reviews learned how to detoxify and
spock tree def is a fungicide that's
registered as a deer repellent and
firearm is the active ingredient high
concentration the firearm of a pretty
decent gary palette though not as good
as the rotten eggs we've done lots of
trials over the years I like to test
deer repellents when the deer of the
hungriest January February March when
we've got 3 4 or 5 inches of snow on the
ground
I'll get horticultural plants this with
Japanese used bald and burlap treat them
indoors under good conditions with
different repellents and take them out
and place them in the landscape when
there's snow cover on the ground and see
what happened when deer really hungry
that gives you a really good test of how
well the repellent work and this is one
of our control use after two weeks in
the field you can see about half the
plant surface area is gone deer tracks
everywhere that's very typical again
using one of the winter candy for deer
around here they love it one of our
repellent trials you can see we tested
the big-game repellent with mix in spray
both different types here also deer off
was interesting egg solids and deer
stopper had petrest and egg solids these
are the top four we saw no damage during
the first four weeks of the experiment
and with these plants in the field and
then you can see what happens they go
downhill pretty quickly so the take-home
message was repellents a decent deer
repellent with Petrus and egg solids or
a really high concentration of capsaicin
a firearm will give you about four to
five weeks of decent protection but then
it loses efficacy of weathers and if
you're around here in the middle of
winter you're not going to be doing any
spraying in January forever
mark so active you've sprayed
late-november say you had a good day to
get some spray on by the end of December
began January that material is gone and
your plants are susceptible so sprays
have their place they tend not to work
for overwinter protection for simple
homeowner applications we've toyed some
with these rope fences and they can be
very effective for small areas white
cotton cord on green snake probably
can't see if there's green cotton cloth
suspended here in the center and we
treated those cloth strips with a
big-game repellant theater bass deer
repellent and as flowerhead density on
that control bed in the ground and the
floor ground was the same as the
planting bed in the background during
summer very simple fences will keep deer
out of small kitchen garden area small
planting areas you don't have to get
something elaborate and expensive
because deer have lots of green stuff to
eat in the summer
that'll fail miserably other times of
the year we've learned a lot about deer
behavior in suburbia in the last 20
years of research and there's a lot of
things that influence deer fleeing
pressure and whether it's mark slicks
whether it's my list I get calls all the
time well so-and-so plants on your deer
resistant Lea and they eat it in my yard
but my neighbor two houses the way they
don't touch it why well it's all these
different things related to deer
behavior population density how many
miles do you have to feed food and cover
sources in travel quarter have you've
got a plant that's relatively deer
resistant most the time that will work
fine and you don't need to protect it
but if your home happens to live on a
travel corridor where deer there
everyday and everynight guess what even
those resistant plants start to getting
and the list don't work all that well
alternative foods plants if deer will
take during spring summer and fall you
get a little snow on the ground tough
winter the hammer in the winter months
when they don't have alternative foods
and the season isn't good deer nutrition
is important what are their fat reserves
like has it been a really tough winter
I've seen dairy vinca to the ground
a pack a cinder which you don't usually
eat at the end of a tough one or when
they're at starvation mode and they're
just trying to put something in the room
and they get through the green up plant
pala bian palatability and nutrients
report deer can sense nitrogen in plant
material what do we do we fertilize our
plants deer know that they're craving
nitrogen and they picked the high
nitrogen plants and natural habitats and
they'll going to pick the highly
fertilize plants in the home landscape
in previous experience I learned the
hard way Bill Miller and I get to trial
years ago with some ornamental and
Asiatic lilies trying to look at deer
resistance a variety and we put
containerized lilies out and in ten
different homeowner site in seven of the
ten sites that the lilies were hammered
nothing survived but yet in three of the
sites deer were in the landscape we got
him on camera and the lilies weren't
touched and I were sitting there
scratching our head what's going on
there's obviously no deer resistance
these lilies they got hammered seven out
of ten sites and what we realized is in
those specific homeowner sites or we had
though there were no other lilies in the
neighborhood deer hadn't recognized them
as food yet and so again an adult doe
will teach her offering what's palatable
and what's not once they sample them
they don't have any protection anymore
because they know it's something good to
eat so again all these behavior things
make it really difficult to predict
sometime what plants will don't be taken
to the landscape these are what I
consider what do you order metals that
are starvation foods for deer and so the
last thing on the list that they'll take
if they're eating Colorado blue spruce
there not much else out there same thing
with boxwood no we talked about earlier
that's a starvation food for deer you'll
notice this list is very short deer will
eat just about anything but you know
with some careful plant selection you
can design a more deer resistant
landscape where you can probably avoid
spraying and probably avoid the cost of
fencing on the other end of the spectrum
these are plant materials that are
frequently severely damaged these are
things deer seek out what do you want
ml's on landscape
you've got your balsam and Fraser firs
on there
your fruit trees things like you want to
miss they love things with big tasty
buds like rhododendrons in azaleas the
ashes used our providing have you've got
these type of plant materials and there
many deer around at all
they're probably going to require
protection during the winter months
they're you're likely to suffer damage
Bill Miller and I did a study with
perennial bulbs decade or so ago looking
at deer resistance of a variety of
different bulbs and we just put about
cafeteria-style and the homeowners yard
and we had again about 2,000 different
cafeterias set up in a home landscape in
a community where there were around 100
deer per square mile we wanted to see
well what's what's typical what survived
at a hundred year four square mile in
either the bulb we're all grown in the
greenhouse here on campus again you can
read down the list I'm not going to
repeat all of them but our control over
tulips we know dear loved tulips and you
tried to grow tulips and dear country
you're probably going to need to protect
them in some way and so we just went out
during the spring and then followed each
of these plants and look at survivorship
and sure enough deer would come along
and pull the pots out of the trays eat
what they liked ignore what they didn't
like and so we could get a really good
measure of what was deer resistance in
terms of perennial bulbs and no big
surprise the mean damage score was
highest for tulips crocuses were highly
favored and then they like counted oxen
and most of the rest of this stuff was
pretty darn deer resistant they rarely
taken their sis's or a highest and
rarely take iris or Allium or things
like that and so most of your spring
bulbs are if you can avoid the tulips
and crocuses are pretty safe but if your
girl have to have two loops and crocuses
better be considering some type of deer
protection we also did cage feeding
trials with voles we had a vole claw on
campus years ago and we gave bulb and
Wade bulb material two pairs of voles in
cages to see the plants that were gear
resistant we're also vole resistant and
sure enough almost everything that
- dear Juanita Volta neither so these
plants have some types of secondary
compound to give them herbivore
resistance or protection the one thing
that was really neat I guess we found
out is this colchicum
actually killed the voles in the trial
we had to stop feeding it I mean it was
toxic that was the only plan on that
list it was toxic but voles just
couldn't even eat the stuff conifers
we've done surveys with tree growers and
again no big surprise here if you're
growing first those are the most
susceptible deer damage and at the
opposite end of the spectrum are your
spruces particularly blue spruce and
your pint white pine of the pines the
most susceptible but there's a land red
pine and occupying aren't that all
that's acceptable so most of the
conifers you can get away with rubbing
damage is not feeding damage and it
doesn't matter how resistant your plants
are when the Bucks are going to rub
trees are going to rub trees and so
again the only way to stop this damage
is a fence tear out of the planting
completely or get a Dec damage permit if
you got safe shooting zones and remove
that problem buck that's causing all of
your problem but a buck might go in on
territory boundary and rub fifty or
hundred trees in one night that could be
a huge economic loss for a grower well
I've just briefly wrap up and talk about
some of the research that we've been
doing on and around campus for the last
decade looking again trying to
understand your behavior and
particularly population ecology
population biology so what we decide to
do most communities that want to control
deer you either you got all the sort of
the animal law for folks and we can't
kill any deer no blood on the snow we
want to go contraceptives and so okay
well that's expensive and you can only
get with a research permit or they get
the other group that wants to shoot them
all and do everything they can to remove
them and they said well why are these
two groups opposed to each other we've
got same goal we want to reduce deer
number so here in clora campus right
where we're sitting we can't carry
firearms or bows I mean you know that's
a real problem yeah we're
dear here a few years ago and yet all
those red lands are Cornell owned
properly mostly the south north and east
of here that are huntable and have been
hunted for decades so he said well I do
wonder there let's do both and see if we
can get some generous energy out of
using both method so we did a
sterilization Tryon core campus so we
could hunt then did a controlled hunting
program on the lands adjacent to camp as
best as we could we captured mark deer
and trap your tag all the deer refet
captured put radio collars on a bunch of
the adult females and then look at their
behavior and movements we took all the
female deer to the College of Veterinary
Medicine we got a lot of willing
students who need some experience and
essentially spayed them just like you
would your dog or your cat and then took
them back out put them on campus under
our research permit just to look at
survivorship movements over time but we
wanted to cut off on production and we
did pretty good at the peak of our
sterilization project we had 95 for some
of the deer on campus sterilized the
female deer and so that would really cut
our phone numbers down to about nothing
and we had some control those 26 mark
controlled all lands north and south the
campus that we can pare against and so
when we looked at movements of mortality
factors if you're an urban deer you
essentially die of one or two ways
either run in front of a motor vehicle
no big surprise or you get into a
huntable area and somebody shoots you
and just like every other study our
study was no different most of our take
all our deer died one of those two ways
we also did population estimation with
infrared triggered cameras over bait
deer come and take their own picture and
cuz we've got them all tagged a high
proportion tag we can do mark-recapture
simulation of modeling and acting at
very reliable estimates of abundance in
the sterilization zone we did a
controlled hunting program it's actually
continues but these are the first few
years of data
Jay Bollinger worked closely with me on
this and we took a pile of deer off
those red zones over the seven-year
first seven years of the program we
removed over seven hundred deer from
those areas so we took seven hundred
deer off campus Lane
we sterilized 95% of our doves what do
you think happened nothing you're
absolutely right
nothing I'll show you the data in a
moment what we had to do to really get
aggressive but our hunting program has
been very popular we provide a lot of
recreation but hunting alone has not
achieved our major goal even though
we've taken over seven our deer through
legal hunting means dr. Barron blassie
has set the oak seedling project on
campus puts out paired northern red oaks
that are raised in greenhouses 20 caged
20 on caged and tagged and plot and look
at survivors as an indicator species we
know deer like the Oaks - biodiversity
and deer impacts that's one of the way
we measure of our programs having any
success so we here's a one of the plots
at the Cornell golf course not far from
there a five-minute walk from where
you're going a bluegrass Lane this
afternoon you can see what our oak
survivorship is it's dismal we can't we
haven't grown Oaks and maples on this
campus in 20 years there's just too many
deer in the woods and so again we're
trying to get at some way to impact this
and turn this around so we can sustain
our natural areas on campus so we
finally decide we got real aggressive
hunting in that work and sterilization
network and not working combined so
that's apply to Dec for a damage per
minute we did the damage permit provides
access to deer and non hunting areas we
can get closer into campus and building
we hand screen and select shooters and
they have to prepare pass proficiency
test being able to take deer at night
with a bow that takes a little bit of
practice not your average hunter these
are the best of the best analysts here
only our permit allows us to use bait at
night we can use lights artificial
lighting on our bows to 11:00 p.m. at
night we campus police approved use of
crossbows and vertical compound bows on
on campus each of those have different
discharge distances under New York state
regs we have to follow all the discharge
distances 250 feet from buildings across
both 150 feet for vertical bows are
limited ears based on the number of DC
tags issue didn't age here they've
issued us
40 for the first couple year we took 34
deer on those 40 permits mostly after
dark I think only one was during normal
hunting hours and then in following year
2014 50 15 we took 37 on our 40 tag at
night and then you're the population
data I mentioned here's all our hunting
and sterilization program you see what
deer are doing here's the first two
years of the damage from it
cut the herd in half the problem is you
got to go to where the deer are and
you've got to have the most skilled
people doing the job right we don't want
crippling loss most those deer are very
smart
the reason hunters don't take them they
go nocturnal they know when it's safe
and we can go out there at night with
lights and special equipment on bows and
take those deer when they feel safe and
we can get into areas that hunters can't
access and that's what caused that
difference over the two years lots of
urban deer management challenges again
both these programs are very expensive
gotta be concerned with public safety
imagine having firearms in the bows
around a campus like this we've worked
very closely with Cornell Police public
values are one when we get some capture
and euthanization under our dec permit
of animal of our groups went went
reserve our university president got
10,000 emails in one day trying to shut
our program down and so again you've got
to work with communication and we had
our communication plan all set up in
case that occurred and we weathered the
storm our program continues gotta have
access to deer I don't care what you're
doing if you can't get to the deer where
they're at you're going to do no good so
that means working with private
landowners working the public land
owners working again we're pleased to
get the access to the points that you
need gotta follow all state laws and
regulations discharged distances are
important setting reasonable goals was
important to what we found our goal we
started this project thinking that by
hunting and sterilization we were going
to reduce deer abundance by 75%
in five years that was our goal we
didn't touch it we never even got close
and so it's just how resilient these
animals are until you work with
you don't understand that sometime and
you got to be working very closely with
police agencies you want more details we
put an extension booklet together free
PDFs available online you can go to the
wildlife control dot info website
there's a number of fact sheets and PDF
format for a variety of urban wildlife
species our deer reports their us info
on ongoing research I thought I'd save a
little paper and folks can go to the
website and download whatever you want
in PDF format with that probably were
running a little bit behind me maybe
there's one or two through quickly the
question was incorporating the venison
donation coalition feeding the hungry
does that change perception absolutely
in fact we've got a program going on a
village that Cuba Heights just north of
campus we started there four years ago
at 125 deer per square mile and now
we're down to 37 deer per square mile on
a damage permit every one of those deer
went the venison donation coalition and
go to the food now it's food bank of the
central tier so yeah that made a huge
difference for a lot of people and gives
us a public support not everybody buys
into it you're still going to get
resistance from really strong animal
welfare advocates but for the general
public yet hugely important
okay what happened 23 years are the
several things that have happened
one is that deer population you really
started to grow exponentially and I
think what happened in particularly nice
suburban areas that aren't hunted
heavily or even hunted at all is we got
to that critical threshold density that
allows the population to go exponential
and we hit that and what we used to have
in the 60s and 70s was every three four
years we got a tough winter what
controls deer abundance in the natural
landscape in New York and northern
Pennsylvania is winter severity and snow
depth one or snow down that's one of the
reasons that deer densities are lowest
in the Adirondacks at anywhere in the
state because the deep persistent snow
that they get up there average deer
density in the Adirondacks are six to
ten per square mile
not a hundred per square mile and at
that long snow duration some deer just
don't survive the land their fat
reserves won't carry him through but
with climate change we've had decade a
couple decades now relatively mild
winter the last winter that was severe
enough here in Ithaca to set deer
population back was the winner of 2002
2003 we haven't had a winner bad enough
to impact the deer herd since then and
the problem is when you do get a winner
in bed and the deer numbers drop that's
when the hunters are out complaining
that deer numbers are down cut the dough
tag we got to build the population back
up that's the time you need to increase
the dome tag and just keep it at it and
you can actually do some good but
there's public resistance to it
predators real predators on the
landscape very rarely to predators
control prey abundance its use of the
exact opposite that's pretty true in
most places with deer there are a few
places in and for example now - Ron -
where you get deep snow where coyotes
for example can have advantage and take
a fair number deer and locally suppress
a herd we don't get that situation
usually in southern New York and in most
states so yeah we've got healthy Keio
populations and then we've got a healthy
Bobcat populations and they're expanding
and yet we've got healthy deer
population so those are plenty of prey
the Predators do well but they don't
really control the
they'll just don't take enough okay
thank you much this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu